this job is so isolating it's very
superficial too there's a superficial
part of streaming you know a lot of
social climbing and all this stuff and
it's just like how do you do
idiot I'm happy you said it this is how
you have to communicate to the side say
things publicly so he watches them on
his stream then he gets angry and then
he'll text you back Hassan is genuinely
people always people are afraid of a
song
with one person if I call him I know he
will answer that's good and I'm saying
that right now and I'm nervous don't
yeah yeah let's see if that works you're
in shaking is he live right now this is
gonna be so good look at this meta right
here this is the internet dude yeah
we're calling him while he's live and
watching his stream at the same time and
filming ours I love this he looked at
his phone okay nice cutie oh he saw it
I'm live what's up oh I just wanted to
say hi and that I missed you
oh okay all right talk to you later [ __ ]
you dude [ __ ] you
oh okay I just wanted to call and say Hi
and then I miss you some girl called me
and said she missed me I don't even know
who it was oh that was Ludwig's girl oh
speaking of which I'm gonna tell your
boyfriend to [ __ ] pay me yes
let's do the round it's gonna be really
awkward if Ludwig doesn't answer now I
have a feeling
you're definitely getting sent to
voicemail it's over this is a voicemail
call
five
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes hey do you owe Cody money
run me my bread five thousand dollars
[Music]
well I can't leave here until you pay
him fine you can't leave there yeah it's
a hostage situation this all seems bad
give us the money yeah or you never see
your cutie again and our executive
producers flirting with us keeps calling
her cutie all right the five thousand's
coming it's coming all right let me know
if you need my venmo or what PayPal
whatever I'll put the location for the
money on a cut.com video
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
one of my favorite things now that I'm
starting to make more friends in La is
when people have a birthday coming up
and I could be like what kind of cake do
you want because then I have like a
purpose to baking a cake whenever I do
baking streams I'll package it all up
and just send it to one of the streamers
houses he was like good luck that's so
cool so I'm slowly gonna fan up all the
streamers in La so you can put them all
in one giant Zorb Ball yeah
exactly welcome to the ultimate
sacrifice event see who gets out yeah
anti Mr Beast I fattened up 25 streamers
and put them in one Zorb Ball the first
one out gets a million dollars I would
watch that
um dude what did you do at Disneyland I
have to know yeah I was Cinderella I was
a fan well there's gonna be I have to
say this every single time there's gonna
be one person in the comment that used
to be a cast member and they're gonna be
like you mean you are friends with
Cinderella oh yes I hang out I hung out
with Cinderella a lot I hung out with
her oh right in your contract as a cast
member if you're a face character you
are not allowed to say what face
character you are but you can say I hung
out with that person wait why I got home
from work today after hanging out with
Sleeping Beauty it was so great because
it breaks the immersion okay yeah yeah
oh I see if you knew I was Cinderella
then it's like she's not real
is she serious that kind of sucks yeah
I'm sorry I'm just dealing with that
right now yeah what the [ __ ] I thought
that but like
Ariel she's real right
that one with the fin yeah that one is
the real one okay yeah good I was
freaking out for a second
Mickey Mouse real Mouse actually just
not steroids oh [ __ ] and lots of
steroids
how does he get his head like that yes
the steroids yeah Trend alone I guess
trembaloney sandwiches what's the
[ __ ] so you just walk around the park
and like hey it's me or you have a Zone
and you can't be out there for too long
because you get overheated obviously and
kids are aggressive and it's actually
not the kids worst part here are the
dads okay um as a princess if a dad
grabs your ass what that happens oh no
yes are you serious you're taking a
photo with the whole family they will
just
no yeah so this is I worked 30 years ago
about I don't want to age myself but
like I'm 25 again so it's like seven
years ago now in days you have to have a
cast member escort you around so every
single face character has someone with
them at all times and usually there's a
code word to get out of a situation
where like for my for example mine was
talking about like Lucifer
um which is Cinderella's stepmom's cat
so I just randomly start bringing up
Lucifer and they pulled me out of the
situation but if your ass is being
grabbed you can't be like stuck because
Cinderella would not say stop you think
if there's any scenario to do that it
would be that one like that yeah they'd
be cool that's crazy as hell to go to
your manager and be like someone grab my
ass I told them to stuff they're like
would Cinderella say stuff have Blair
have you read the lore book yes that's
not really part of Cinderella's
character yeah that's that's psycho yeah
there was one time I I tried to get out
of it by saying like so you get
evaluated on there's three things you
can evaluated on uh like your your look
is a weird way to say it but like you
know you can't if you have to look like
the character you have to be a certain
size literally oh damn so this is It's
toxic it's pretty toxic uh not to throw
Disney on the bus but they they get away
with it because it's you're a cast
member you've been cast in this you're
an actor right if you're playing Dorothy
for years and years and years Hollywood
has gotten away with if you're playing
Dorothy you have to be this size you
have to be this color you have to be
this so it's it's shitty but yeah you
can get away with it so you have to make
sure that you fit the measurements of
your dress and wow otherwise you know
you're screwed and also your your
storytelling is something you get rated
on so if you came to me as Cinderella
and you're a little kid and you're like
I love pizza what's your favorite food
Cinderella's not eating pizza yeah so I
have to say pumpkin stew I love pumpkin
stew have you ever had pumpkins too like
you have to always figure out how to
bring it back to your story also
characters they don't know other
characters outside of their story so
even though Mickey Mouse is standing
over there Cinderella doesn't know
Mickey Mouse so if the kid says I just
saw Mickey Mouse you say mouse I have a
mouse Named Gus Gus like you have to
bring it back to you yeah yeah so you've
been streaming a long time
yes that was a chat in real life yeah
now behind the screen